PROFESSOR: All right, I
thought he would be.
It's always a hazard putting
up somebody who you know is
going to lecture better
than you do.
But I hope that was a
good change of pace.
And, of course, he knows more
about the subject of
Reed-Solomon decoding than I
or more than practically
anyone else does, so --
did he have much time to
talk about decoding or
was the most -- yeah.
Talked about the decoding
algorithms, Sudan-type
decoding algorithms.
Yeah?
OK.
Good.
Well, in fact, he covered so
much that I don't have much
left to do today.
I remind you, Ashish
put out an email.
There's a review session
tomorrow for the midterm from
5 to 7 in a different
room, 36-112.
The midterm is Wednesday
in this room.
It starts at 9:05 to give
you a little bit more
time to work on it.
It's closed book except that
you're allowed to make up
three normal size
sheets of notes.
You can write as small
as you like.
This experience has shown this
is the very best way of
getting you to consolidate what
you've learned up to this
point, is writing your own
three-page precis of the
course to date.
So, yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What is
the rule, both --
what?
AUDIENCE: Both sides.
PROFESSOR: Both sides.
All right.
Six sheets.
If you can't write down the
whole course in six sheets,
then, well, you haven't
been paying attention.
OK.
And you can bring calculators,
but we don't
expect they'll be useful.
Please erase any erasable will
memories if you do bring
calculators.
These are things we tell
undergraduates.
I guess they hardly
seem necessary
in a graduate course.
Any other questions about the
logistics of the midterm?
AUDIENCE: What is the material
going to be for the midterm?
PROFESSOR: Everything that's
been covered up to today.
I won't hold you responsible
for anything I've
talked about today.
So it's basically chapters
one through eight.
I really will only hold you
responsible for what we
covered in class, which chapters
one, two, and three
were so brief, you can't say
we really covered them.
So really, chapters four
through eight.
Any other questions?
All right.
You'll have more chance
as we go along.
So as I say, Ralf really covered
the main things about
Reed-Solomon codes, which are
the crowning achievement of
algebraic coding theory.
They have a lot of favorable
attributes.
They are optimum, from an n,
k, d point of view, in the
sense that they're maximum
distance separable.
The parameters are as good as
they possibly could be by this
very basic Singleton bound.
They have efficient algebraic
decoding algorithms.
And traditionally, this has
meant hard decision bounded
distance decoding algorithms
like the Welch-Berlekamp
algorithm or the
Berlekamp-Massey match
algorithm, which take hard
decisions in, put hard
decisions on symbols out.
But as Ralf suggested to you,
now there are algorithms that
can use soft decisions in,
produce a list, at least,
coming out, some indication
of the reliability of each
element of the list.
So they've been softened up.
Nonetheless, what are the
negatives is, basically, that
they work on bytes, or
symbols, not bits.
So if we have a basically binary
channel, as we very
frequently do, then they need
something else to make them
adapted to the binary channel,
or even on the additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
I don't think we've gone through
the calculation.
You could think of sending q or
e symbols over the additive
white Gaussian noise channel,
but what would you need?
You would need a q
or e signal set.
Now, if you pick that to be a
q simplex signals set or a
orthogonal or biorthogonal
signal set, then that might
work because the distance
structure of such a signal set
is like the Hamming distance
structure in GF of q.
In other words, it's
approximately equally likely
to make an error to
any other symbol.
The symbols are more or less
equally spread apart in
Euclidean space.
Just as when we count distance
in Hamming space, we give the
same weight to each possible
kind of error or each possible
kind of symbol difference.
So if you did that,
then Reed-Solomon
codes might work well.
That's one form of a
concatenated scheme, which I
will talk about in
just a second.
But if you tried to apply
Reed-Solomon codes to a binary
input additive white Gaussian
noise channel, just translate
the, say, 8-bit bytes into bits
and send them one bit at
a time, then the distance
structures don't
correspond at all well.
It's much more likely to make
a single bit error than an
error that involves all eight
bits or something.
And for that fundamental reason,
you'll find that
performance is not so great.
And certainly, this is not the
way to get to capacity all by
itself unless it's married
with something else.
So that's something we always
have to deal with in another
applications, as I will talk
about in a minute.
We naturally do want
to correct bytes,
or symbols, or blocks.
There are many bits.
And then Reed-Solomon codes are
just exactly what we want.
They're optimal in any
such situation.
And so what did I just say?
They're not the way to get to
capacity, although they are
sometimes part of schemes
for getting to capacity.
And since getting to capacity in
the additive white Gaussian
noise channel is the theme of
this course, then they play
only a peripheral role
in that theme.
Nonetheless, they're
great codes.
They're in wide use.
They're part of every
semiconductor manufacturer's
core library.
You can buy (255,223) distance
33, 16 error correcting
Reed-Solomon decoder in part of
any chip package and it'll
go at gigabits nowadays.
So it's kind of the all-purpose
error correcting
code, with the caveat that you
need to somehow get what you
correct to be bytes rather
than bits, OK?
So today I thought I'd cover the
last two topics in chapter
eight and maybe, to the extent
that time permits, go back to
chapter seven.
But we'll see how we
feel about that.
Applications of Reed-Solomon
codes.
OK, basically, you can apply
them wherever you want to
correct blocks, rather than bits
or packets or n-tuples or
what have you.
So one obvious application is,
when you send packets through
the internet, if you use
Reed-Solomon codes across the
packet, then you can correct
errors that occur in
individual packets.
This is not the way the internet
usually works.
The internet usually works by
having an error detection code
within each packet, a cyclic
redundancy check (CRC).
You hash bits, whatever.
You provide some redundant bits
within each packet if --
when you receive the packet, you
check to see whether the
parity check checks.
If there are parity check bits,
then a very good rule of
thumb is that the probability of
not detecting an error for
almost any type of error pattern
is going to be of the
order of 2 to the minus r.
That's exactly what it would
be if you had a completely
random stream of bits.
Random stream of bits with r
redundant bits in a block, the
probability that all the check
bits are random, the
probability that they're
all equal to 0, is 2
to the minus r.
All right?
But it turns out that's very
good approximation for just
about any error mechanism.
So you pick r large enough.
It's often been picked to be
something like r equals 32.
What kind of failure to
detect does that give?
2 to the minus 32, which is
what, about 2 the minus 9th, 2
to the minus 10th --
10 to the minus 9th, 10
to the minus 10th.
Is that low enough?
It was certainly --
when I started in this business,
that was considered
just incredibly low, but now
that we're sending mega
packets per second, it doesn't
seem quite so low anymore.
And so 32 is a little bit
on the sloppy side.
There are going to be undetected
errors that get
through if you're spending
10 to the 9th,
10 to the 10th packets.
But 32 or, nowadays, 64 would
be a better number.
Just like cryptography, the
number of bits has to go up as
technology goes up.
But 32 is often used.
OK, but here's an alternative
scheme.
Suppose you coded
across packets.
So here is a, say, a
1,000-bit packet.
And here's packet one, here's
packet two, here's packet
three, and so forth up to packet
k, where we're going to
use n, k, d equals n minus k
plus 1, RS code over, it
doesn't matter, GF of let's
say 256, just for definite
[INAUDIBLE].
Here I'm using older notation.
This is the same as F-256.
Or we sometimes write that
as F 2 to the 8th.
OK, how are we going to do
packet error correction?
We're going to code crosswise
in columns, all right?
So these would be k.
Let's make this eight-wide.
Just pick off a bite
at a time here.
So each of these can be
considered to be a
symbol in GF of 256.
And then we'll code n
minus k parity check
packets down here.
So these are redundant
check packets.
Encoded bytes at this point.
They're not packets yet.
But if we do that column-wise
across here, we can fill in n
minus k check packets and you
can see the block length is
quite huge here.
So you might have a delay or
latency problem in executing
this scheme.
Basically, you would have to
send this whole thing before
you could do error correction
and then error correct the
whole thing.
But how does error
correction work?
You send this.
Perhaps some of the packets are
erased or even received
incorrectly.
You would then use some error
correction or erasure and
error correction scheme, which
Ralf talked about, for
correcting the Reed-Solomon
code.
And you could correct up to d
over 2 errors, or up to d
minus 1 erasures, OK?
So this would be a very
powerful packet error
correction scheme.
What are its costs?
It's costs are quite a
bit of redundancy.
It doesn't fit the internet
architecture very well.
This is basically a
point-to-point scheme.
So when you're sending from a to
b, you'd have to send b an
additional n minus k streams.
And if you're sending the same
webpage, as you often do, to
multiple people, you'd have
to send this to everybody.
And it also doesn't have
any feedback in it.
The great thing about ARQ is
that you only have to send the
information that's necessary.
You only have to restore
the packets that
are actually lost.
You send them again.
Whereas here, you're just kind
of, a priori, deciding that
you're going to send a great
deal of redundant information
down here to cover some kind
of worst case, whatever you
think the worst-case number
of packets would be.
If there are more that
worst-case number or packets,
then you could retransmit
again, but you're
retransmitting this huge
block, all right?
So for that reason, this is not
actually used, as far as
I'm aware, in the internet.
ARQ, wherever you have
a feedback path,
you should use it.
That's a general moral.
So ARQ is a wonderful scheme
that is, on an erasure
channel, that's a
capacity-approaching scheme.
Just on a bitwise basis, if
you have a binary erasure
channel with erasure probability
p, and then the
capacity of the channel is 1
minus p, and you can reach
that capacity if you simply
retransmit each
bit that was erased.
As it's erased --
it's erased, you
send it again.
And a quick calculation shows
you that the average number of
retransmissions is p.
And so the average reduction
from 1 bit per second is --
1 bit per transmission is p bits
per transmission, you can
achieve 1 minus p with no
coding at all, just by
retransmission.
So it's perfectly matched
to the erasure channel.
And the internet, especially
with parity checks, CRC,
within blocks, long enough
CRC is basically a
packet erasure channel.
You really, in practice,
hardly ever make
a undetected --
let a packet with errors
come through.
OK?
Any questions about this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The TCP/IP protocol
just has a 32-bit CRC, I
think, and if it fails to check,
you ask for that packet
again by packet number.
OK?
So Reed-Solomon codes, of
course, are optimal if that's
what you want to do.
You couldn't possibly have
a better code for
coding across packets.
But it's cumbersome in the
packet environment.
OK.
Let's talk about concatenated
codes.
I guess I'll do it at
the same place.
This is something --
I did in my thesis and last
week I was at a tribute to
Andy Viterbi, who invented
the Viterbi
algorithm, among other things.
Of course, everybody knows that
the Viterbi algorithm,
when Andy invented it, he had no
idea it was actually going
to be a practical algorithm.
It's become one of the super
practical algorithms.
He was just trying to prove a
certain result, exponential
error bounds for convolutional
codes.
And he thought the proof was
easier to understand if you
introduce this algorithm, which
he describes perfectly.
It is the Viterbi algorithm.
But really, just a
proof technique.
Didn't even realize it was
an optimum decoder.
And then somebody, not him, not
me, but in his company,
fortunately, realized
that gee, this
could be very practical.
And that became a workhorse
decoding algorithm.
Very similarly, concatenated
codes are something that I did
in my thesis in 1965.
And I was looking, basically,
for a theoretical result.
How could you approach capacity
with an exponentially
decreasing error probability
near capacity but with only
polynomial increasing
complexity?
And I looked into this very
simple idea of basically
taking two codes and using
one to correct the
errors of the other.
And I found that you
could do that.
And I'd also never realized
that this
might actually be practical.
I remember going around giving
talks when I was interviewing
afterwards that I was looking
for an industrial position.
I went down to places like Bell
Labs, IBM labs, and did
seminars talking about codes
that were thousands of symbols
long and everybody rolled their
eyes and said, boy, this
guy is not very practical.
And to my surprise and everyone
else's surprise, this
became and still is a very
practical way of getting
high-performance codes.
This, in conjunction --
well, I'll get into it, but this
was, again, a workhorse
coding technique and still
is in wide use.
In fact, as you will see, this
contains some of the ideas
that go into modern
capacity-approaching codes.
But the idea is very simple.
You can do it two ways, or
probably many more than two.
Suppose we have a basically
binary channel.
I'll just say a core physical
channel there.
The channel is what you can't
affect as an engineer.
So let's say we have a binary
symmetric channel or a binary
input additive white Gaussian
noise channel or
whatever you like.
And then we could put on it an
encoder and decoder for an n,
k, d binary linear block code.
OK?
Now, from the input and the
output, what is this channel
going to look like?
At the input, we're putting --
basically, per block,
we put k bits in.
They're encoded into n bits.
They're sent over the channel,
received some n-tuple of noisy
received symbols.
The decoder tries to find
the best code word.
The code word is identified
by k bits.
Most of the time there'll
be no error and these --
let's call this u in
and u hat out.
u hat is going to equal u.
But, of course, let's
imagine this is a
relatively short code.
Let's imagine this is a maximum
likelihood decoder or
minimum distance decoder in
the appropriate space.
Then the complexity is
going to be of the
order of 2 to the k.
And so you can't let
k get very big.
We'll find somewhat
better ways to do
maximum likelihood decoding.
But if you're really trying to
do optimum decoding, the
complexity is going to go up
exponentially at this stage
with the number of information
bits k.
So this is not the scheme that
we're looking for that has
only polynomial complexity.
We know that we can choose
codes like this that with
optimum decoding get
to capacity.
That's Shannon's theorem.
But we don't know how to decode
them with reasonable
complexity.
But, all right, here's
a start.
We could use a relatively modest
length code that we can
feasibly decode.
And this is what we get.
OK.
So we have blocks going in.
Block from an alphabet
of size 2 to the k.
Blocks coming out, alphabet
size 2 to the k.
Occasionally, we make errors.
What's a good idea to then do?
This is not very hard.
This is why you should have been
in this field in the '60s
rather than the year 2005.
There were lots of good ideas
just laying around waiting to
be picked up.
Class?
Anyone have a suggestion
for how to make further
improvement in this system?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Add another code.
What should it be?
Let's put an encoder
here for what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Everyone is
extremely wide awake.
An n, k, d Reed-Solomon
code over what field?
In principle, it should
be over F2 to the k.
Now, of course, if k is 64 or
something here, you might not
even go all the way to field
of 2 to the 64 elements.
You might divide it up again as
we did in the packet error
correction.
But basically, the way this goes
is you try to keep this
as small as possible so that
this can still work.
There's a tradeoff between the
complexity of the two codes
and therefore, the rates.
The decoder --
here we have an algebraic
Reed-Solomon decoder, which,
in the simplest case, could
just do error correction.
Just take these k bits as a hard
decision on u hat and try
to correct any errors that
occurred in this inner loop
here, which we might think
of this as being a
2 to the kre channel.
So this whole thing
together is a 2 to
the kre super channel.
Sorry if you can't read that,
but you heard me say it.
So here's a channel that takes
in 2 to the kre symbols, puts
out 2 to the kre symbols and
sometimes makes errors
according to whatever the error
probability you can
achieve here is.
Or some of the discussion back
when we were talking about
hard decision with binary
suggested that it would be
better to pass along more
reliability information here
along with just the
hard decision.
And the very simplest kind of
reliability information is if
this guy really isn't sure, if
either the noise is too large
so he can't make any decision
or if the noise leaves him
exactly halfway between two
code words so it's a
completely ambiguous decision,
or whatever criteria you have,
this might make erasures.
And I'm sure Ralf told you how
to do error and erasure
correction with Reed-Solomon
codes.
Or this could be more likely
that information just --
how likely was the code
word you actually saw?
And there are various ways of
devising an approximate
likelihood metric.
You just do what makes sense
that indicates that some
words, you're absolutely sure
of in this decoding.
And other words, you
don't know --
if you have one or more good
candidates or you have no good
candidates.
So based on this reliability
information, you can actually
incorporate that.
Did Ralf talk about
reliability-based decoding?
Soft decoding algorithms
for Reed-Solomon codes?
No?
OK, well, that's a shame because
he and Alex Vardy are
the inventors of a very
good class that's
recently been improved.
So one of the knocks on
Reed-Solomon codes is that, at
one point, you might have said
a minus can only work with
hard decisions.
And then, fairly early,
it was figured out how
to correct to erasures.
But just in the last 10
years, we now have --
this is no longer true.
We can have soft, meaning
reliability-labeled inputs.
And this is a plus.
That means we can do soft --
and we have corresponding
algorithms that can do soft
Reed-Solomon decoding.
They are, of course, more
complicated than just
straightforward error
correction with hard decisions.
But there's still polynomial
complexity.
They're maybe an order of
slightly higher degree of n,
but still polynomial in the
block length or in k or d or
whatever you're taking.
And so we now have some such
algorithms that do make
substantial gains.
And, of course, if he didn't
tell you about them, I'm not
going to tell you about them.
It's a rather specialized
subject.
But it's something
that's really
happened the last 10 years.
And they've constantly
been improved.
The first ones, like one
I came up with called
generalized minimum distance
decoding, made a modest
improvement.
In dB terms, 1 dB, where
there's 3 dB to be got.
Now they're up to 2, 2 1/2 out
of the 3 dB with these new
soft Reed-Solomon decoding
algorithms.
So anyway, if you pass some
reliability information here,
then you can improve the
performance of this decoder.
This decoder knows which symbols
are reliable and it
won't change in the decoding
in which are unreliable or
completely erased.
Where there's no information
about them, that actually
helps you in the decoding.
If you knew that you had s
erasures rather than s errors,
this helps you quite a lot.
We can decode twice as
many erasures as
we can decode errors.
And similarly, soft information
in between can
improve the capabilities
of your decoder.
All right.
So that's the set up.
You can see why it makes a
certain amount of sense.
From a complexity point of
view, what it does --
here, we're going to do maximum
likelihood decoding,
complexity order
of 2 to the k.
But we're not going
to let k get very
large, so this is feasible.
Then we're going to let the code
get very long, as we know
we have to do from Shannon's
Theorem,
using this outer code.
But now we know we have
polynomial complexity
Reed-Solomon decoding
algorithms, even for the soft
decision case.
So if we balance the complexity
here, basically let
this length be exponential and
this length, as it is -- it's
of the order of 2 to
the k itself --
then we can get polynomial
complexity overall, all right?
The overall complexity is going
to be of the order of a
small power of 2 to the k.
The overall block length is
going to be of the order --
is going to be linear
in 2 to the k.
And therefore, you're going
to get polynomial decoding
complexity.
The other question
is performance.
And you can show
that if you --
well, even if you don't use
reliability information, you
can get all the way to the
capacity of this underlying
channel here with
exponentially-decreasing error
rate for any rate below
that capacity.
Not as good an exponent as if
you just used random codes per
Shannon and coded for the
channel, but nonetheless, you
basically get what you want.
So using two smaller, simpler
codes to create one long code
turned out to be a good idea.
First of all, for proving this
theoretical result, you could
get exponentially-decreasing
error rate for polynomial
increasing decoding
complexity.
And within about 10 years,
this is what
people actually did.
And, in fact, what people
actually did --
I've got a block code here, but
what people actually did
was they used a short
constraint length
convolutional code here,
which we'll be talking
about after the break.
Convolutional codes tend to
have a better performance
complexity tradeoff,
particularly in soft decision
situations than block
codes do.
So in a practical system, it's
almost always better to use a
convolutional code than
a block code.
We'll discuss the reasons why.
So this convolutional code
here, there is a maximum
likelihood sequence detector
for the convolutional code
down here, which is the Viterbi
algorithm, which
you've probably all
heard about.
And this is very practical as
long as the constraint length,
k, now becomes the constraint
length, nu, of the code
doesn't get too large.
So for about 20 years, the
standard for space
communication was this was a
(255, 223, 33) Reed-Solomon
code over F-256.
This is a constraint length 6,
rate 1/2 convolutional code.
This is a 64-state Viterbi
algorithm.
So what's the --
again, if we have a look at the
error channel, here is a
stream of bits coming along.
After encoding and decoding,
what we typically see is
bursts of errors, all right?
So you get a burst
that starts --
in convolutional codes, it can
start at a random time, end at
a random time.
You might get another discrete
error event over here.
In other words, most
of the time, the
decoder is decoding properly.
What you're receiving is what
you transmitted in a
streamwise fashion.
The bits just are transmitted
forever.
But every so often, the decoder
gets off on the wrong
track, puts out errors for
a while, then gets
resynchronized, and decodes
correctly again.
Is my picture clear?
I'm using words, mainly, to tell
you what it represents.
OK.
So now, basically, what you want
to do is, just as we did
in the packet communication
case, you want to send
multiple parallel streams, up
to 256 of them, such that in
this stream, you're going to get
independent error blocks.
And this one, you're
going to get errors
occurring somewhere else.
They're going to have
a typical length.
You can very well estimate what
the typical length of
error events is, but they
occur randomly.
And now you use the Reed-Solomon
code, coding
across this, and that will
basically give you this
picture over here.
How would I get this?
One way is by using a block
interleaver, which is
described in the notes.
A block interleaver, you
basically take a long block
from the convolutional code
and you just encode and
transmit along here and
ultimately decode.
And after a very long time,
you come back and start
transmitting the second
row just as
part of the same stream.
And then the third
row and so forth.
And if the block length n,
here, is long enough, the
errors in different rows
will be effectively
independent, all right?
So again, you wind up with
very long blocks in this
scheme, but analytically,
it works.
And in practice, this is roughly
what's done, except
there is such a thing as a
convolutional interleaver,
which again, operates streamwise
and actually
performs better in practice.
But I won't take the time to go
into this because we're not
going to really be getting into
things like interleavers.
Do you see how this works?
OK.
So it works well
theoretically.
It gives us the theoretical
result we want.
Works well in practice.
As I say, this was the
standard for space
communications during the
'70s and the '80s.
Around the end of the '80s,
they upgraded this.
First of all, they replaced this
by a nu equals 14, rate
1/6, lower rate convolutional
code, so this now becomes a 2
to the 1fourth state
Viterbi decoder.
They built this huge rack at
JPL that had 8,192 parallel
decoding units,
add-compare-select units in
the Viterbi algorithm,
to decode this thing.
But, of course, they only need
to do that in one place, in
the space program.
Everything comes back to JPL.
So they built this BVD,
Big Viterbi decoder.
And first, they used it with
this code and then they souped
up the Reed-Solomon code.
And by about 1990, 1991, they
got this thing operating up
within about 2 dB of the
Shannon limit, OK?
Which was considered a heroic
feat at the time, or even now.
So that kind of tells you, in
the terms we've been using in
this course, just what
you can get out of
this kind of approach.
At that point, that was
considered coding is dead.
There's really nothing
more to do.
We're within about 2 dB of the
Shannon limit and it's
inconceivable that we
could actually get
any closer than that.
Second half of the course will,
of course, tell us how
we can get within 0.0045 dB
of the Shannon limit.
But that was the state of
the art as of about
1990, 15 years ago.
Questions?
Comments?
OK.
All right.
I'll just mention a third
application is burst error
correction, which really,
we've already
been talking about.
Suppose --
let's let this be a
naked channel now.
Suppose you're transmitting
with an
interleave scheme like this.
And now, in the same way --
it's a radio channel or
something and every so often,
you have an outage just due to
fading, or a thunderstorm, or
somebody turns on his vacuum
cleaner, or whatever.
Every so often, as you
transmit, you're
going to get bursts.
You don't have independent,
identically-distributed errors.
The character of the channel is
such that you see bursts of
errors, which is precisely
what you do in this super
channel here.
Every so often, you see a bunch
of errors if you have
the original transmitted scheme
to compare it to.
All right.
In exactly the same way,
you can code --
with something like this block
interleaver, you can code
across channels and correct
the bursts with
Reed-Solomon codes.
And here, it's quite easy
to show that, because
Reed-Solomon codes have optimal
parameters n, k, d,
that Reed-Solomon codes do
the best possible job of
correcting burst errors that you
possibly could do, given
some specification for how long
the bursts could possibly
be and the minimum guard
space between bursts.
This is classical stuff.
Reed-Solomon codes are optimum
burst correctors if you
describe the burst channel by
max burst length in a minimum
guard space.
Is that too brief?
Probably is.
Give you some impression of
what we're talking about.
So Reed-Solomon codes are
optimum for burst error
correction, which, most real
channels are bursty.
The only non-bursty channel
that we really have is the
additive white Gaussian noise
channel, ultimately.
That is the channel in space
communications, which is why
you can apply a nice,
textbook-type code like this
to the space channel.
For any other channel,
typically, you have to use
some kind of interleaving to
break up the bursts so
that you can --
this simply is no information
over a long time.
If you tried to encode crossways
on this, you'd have
to have a code that's long
enough to see the average
burst's behavior.
We'd make the burst have
an ergodic model.
The way to do that in practice
is to code across it so you
get independent snippets of
widely separated bursts which
can be assumed to
be independent.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No different,
really.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in space
channel -- all right.
Here, I'm talking about
power limit.
That's a good question.
But if you think about the
band-limited regime,
let's suppose --
so this would be some
[? MRE ?] channel.
You would use some multilevel
signaling scheme like QAM with
a large signal set or QPSK or
something like that to get a
basic transmission with a
discrete signal set that
doesn't lose too much
over sending
Gaussian over the channel.
Again, this will be later
in the course.
We'll talk about
this in detail.
Other than that --
well, all right, so now this
is an MRE channel.
If M is large enough, then you
could apply Reed-Solomon codes
right here.
But typically, it's not.
M is like 16 or 64.
And so Reed-Solomon codes would
still be too short.
You would not be able
to get long enough
codes over such a channel.
So a similar kind of
thing can be done.
And the history of
bandwidth-limited coding
pretty much parallels that
of power-limited coding.
What corresponds to block codes
here is lattice codes
for this channel.
What corresponds to
convolutional codes is
trellis-coded modulation.
And again, once you handle the
basic physical channel with
these codes that are well
matched to that channel but
whose complexity increases too
rapidly if you make them long
because of exponential decoding,
then you can always
clean up whatever
errors you make.
You can think of this as a
cleanup function out here.
Typically, the rates out
here are very high.
You don't need much
redundancy.
It doesn't cost too much
in overall rate.
But even with very high rates,
like 223 over 255, you can do
a rather large amount
of error correction.
You can correct up to
16 errors or 32
erasures with us channel.
So this is a cleanup function.
You basically work very hard
in here, get the best error
probability you can, which --
it doesn't have to be too low.
10 to the minus 2, 10
to the minus 3.
And then you use this to clean
it up and that drives the
error probability down to 10 to
the minus 12 or 10 to the
minus 15 or whatever
you really want.
But the principles are
the same in power
limit and band limit.
But nice question.
Any other questions?
OK.
So as a result, Reed-Solomon
codes are the general purpose
code that has emerged from
algebraic coding theory.
A good example of burst error
correction is, you know on
your CDs, there is an error
correction scheme incorporated
such that if you scratch
the CD, it still works.
How does that work?
It could only be because
there's some error
correction in there.
What, actually, is the error
correction scheme?
I'm not sure I know what the
latest and greatest is, but
generally, the error correction
schemes for
magnetic memory recording
like that have used
Reed-Solomon codes --
have used two Reed-Solomon
codes in interleave
fashion like this.
So the across code
is Reed-Solomon.
The down code is Reed-Solomon.
As a result, if you make a
scratch through the disc, you
will cut all of these codes, but
you will cut each one in a
small enough place so that
you can correct it.
So you can think of this as a
actually a physical laying
down of Reed-Solomon codes on
the two-dimensional surface of
the disc in such a way that --
well, even if your scratch came
right across one whole
channel here, then, of course,
this decoder would be dead.
But you still have somebody
decoding in this direction to
pick up the errors.
And so that's why you can
completely abuse these discs
and they still work.
And when you think about what's
actually going on,
think of the transfer rates from
a CD to your computer.
It's up in the hundreds of
millions of bits per second.
Maybe its gigabits by now.
Perhaps it is.
And you've got this
Reed-Solomon --
these are non-trivial
Reed-Solomon decoders.
These are like this 16 error
correcting decoder out here.
And so these are working away at
that data rate, capable of
doing decoding.
And they're cheap enough so that
they're just buried in
part of one of the integrated
circuits in
your disc player circuitry.
So that'd give you a physical
sense for just how much error
correction power and speed you
can get out of this class of
code decoder, OK?
So wherever you want an
extremely powerful code and
you're a little bit less
concerned with getting to
capacity, Reed-Solomon code
is the way to go.
It's absolutely part of
your toolbox, OK?
The last topic in chapter eight
is BCH codes, which are
binary codes.
So they're binary linear block
codes of the class we've been
discussing, comparable with
Reed-Muller codes.
Reed-Muller codes were
discovered in 1954 in two
separate papers by Reed
and by Muller in two
separate points of view.
And there are a million points
of view you can have for
Reed-Muller codes.
We've used yet a third one.
BCH stands for Bose and
Chaudhury and Hocquenghem.
Bose and Chaudhury were both
professors in the US.
They wrote a paper about 1960
introducing Reed-Solomon
codes, which, by the way, and
introducing BC codes --
Bose-Chaudhury codes --
Reed-Solomon's paper
was in 1960 also.
These were completely
independent of each other.
And then this fellow named
Hocquenghem in France, whose
name I can't and few people can
pronounce, turned out he
had actually invented these
codes in 1959 in a paper that
unfortunately was in French,
so few people read it.
But anyway, in honor of all
three of these people, these
are called BCH codes.
These fit right into the main
theme of algebraic coding
theory at that time.
Maybe stimulated it because
these turned out to be cyclic
codes, or at least as they were
originally introduced.
And so when I was in school,
which was in the early '60s,
these were considered the
greatest thing going.
People were interested in binary
codes, algebraic codes
because they are slightly better
than Reed-Muller codes.
Now, I would say, there's sort
of been a swing back.
Shu Lin gave a paper about
10 years ago that said
Reed-Muller codes
are not so bad.
In fact, in terms of performance
versus complexity
for certain kinds of decoding
schemes, trellis-based
decoding, Reed-Muller codes
are better than BCH codes.
So from a more modern
prospective, we're more
interested in Reed-Muller
than we are in BCH.
Nonetheless, you'll hear about
these a lot if you read the
literature and so you ought
to know what they are.
OK.
Conceptually, what are they?
Since we already know about
Reed-Solomon codes, the way
that I'm going to characterize
BCH codes is as subfield
subcodes of the Reed-Solomon
codes.
Now, if we have a Reed-Solomon
code over F2 to the 8 or
something, the field with 256
elements, or any power of 2,
contains a subfield which is
just 0 and 1, all right?
All fields contains 0 and 1.
If the field has characteristic
2, then 0 and 1
all by themselves are
the prime subfield.
So it's possible that there
are certain words in the
Reed-Muller code -- sorry, in
the Reed-Solomon code that are
completely made up
of 0's and 1's.
For instance, the all-0 word
is certainly in the
Reed-Solomon code, so we have,
at least, that one that's made
up of all zeros.
Almost always, we find that the
all-1 word is a code word.
So we have a code with
all 0's and all 1's.
And there might be
more of them.
And that's actually very
straightforward, to find out
how many completely binary
words there are in a
Reed-Solomon code.
So it's the binary subfield.
We have F2 is a subfield of F2
to the M for all M. OK, so a
subfield subcode, if we have
an n, k, d equals n minus k
plus 1 Reed-Solomon code, then
the set of all BCH code is the
set of all binary code words,
code words that just use the 0
and 1 of the code alphabet.
Call this c in C. So we
call this C prime.
OK, so what are its parameters
going to be?
Its length is still going
to be n, right?
All the code words here are
n-tuples, so these have got to
be n-tuples.
We don't know its dimension.
Let's just call it k prime.
That's how many such code
words are there?
We're going to have to
do some combinatorics
to find that out.
And what's the minimum
distance going to be?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: In general, well,
it's certainly not going to be
less than because, by definition
of the minimum
distance, the minimum Hamming
distance between any two code
words in this code is d, so
we're just looking at a subset
of the code words
in this code.
And the minimum squared distance
has to be at least d.
There's an example given
in the notes.
If we let c be the 4, 3 --
I think it's the 4, 2, 3, over
F4, then C prime turns out to
be the 4, 1, 4 code over F2.
In other words, the only two
code words in this code that
are all binary are the all-0
and all-1 sequences.
All right?
So we actually get a minimum
distance of 4.
It has to be at least 3 in
this particular case, so
here's an example where it
could be greater than 3.
Or if there are cases where the
subcode just consists of
the all-0 word, then that, by
convention, has an infinite
minimum distance.
So distance could be greater,
but it never can be less than
what you started with.
On the other hand,
the dimension is
clearly going to go down.
If it were still equal to what
it was, then we'd have a
binary MDS code and we know we
don't get binary MDS codes.
So in general, k prime decreases
quite a bit.
In this case, it just
decreases by 1.
And we have to find out
how it decreases.
OK.
I'm a little uncertain as to how
much of the derivation --
so we need to find --
AUDIENCE: Is that [INAUDIBLE]
at all points of
the field, is it?
PROFESSOR: No.
One of the characterizations
you have of Reed-Solomon
codes, I assume, was that
they're the set of all
polynomials of length n that
evaluate to 0 at some
consecutive set of n minus
k powers of alpha.
Did you see anything
like that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: All right.
In other words, they're --
let me write that down because
RS code is the set of all
multiples f of x, g of x, of
degree less than n where of g
of x equals the product of x
minus alpha to the i for i
equals 0 to n minus k minus one
or something like that.
This is called a generator
polynomial and --
so what does this mean?
In other language, all
polynomials of degree less
than n that have roots
at 1 alpha, alpha
squared, or so forth.
It's better to make this i
equals 1 to n minus k.
You can also make it minus i.
There are lots of
details in here.
But I'll just ask you broadly
to recall that
characterization.
This is a --
AUDIENCE: I have another
question.
[INAUDIBLE] are not linear?
PROFESSOR: OK, let's ask that.
So we've got a set of
binary n-tuples, OK,
defined as the subset.
So what do we need to
do to see whether
it's linear or not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: We just check
the group property.
Is it closed under addition?
Suppose we take two of these
code words we add them
together, component-wise,
vector form.
Seems to me we get A, that gives
us another code word in
the Reed-Solomon code because
it's closed under addition,
and B, by the addition rules,
it's going to be another
binary code word, all right?
So it's another binary code
word in the RS code,
therefore, it's in C prime.
So that's proof that, in fact,
this code is linear.
AUDIENCE: What about
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's trivial.
For a binary code, we only
have to consider two
scalars, 0 and 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: But now I'm
asking whether this
binary code is linear.
There's the code over F2.
Yes?
You had a --
AUDIENCE: Same question.
The base field is F2 to the x,
so if you add 1 and 1 there,
it wouldn't be just 0.
But I guess if you restrict the
field to F2, you have to
check everything again,
don't you?
PROFESSOR: No, because we said
F2 is the subfield of F2 to
the M. And what we actually
showed was that if you just
stay in the prime field, the
integers of the field, then
you get exactly the same
addition and multiplication
rules as you do in
the prime field.
So in fact, in a field of
characteristic 2, we always
have 0 plus 1 is 1, 0 plus 1
plus 0 is 1, 1 plus 1 is 0.
That last one is the only one
you really have to check.
So that accounts for the
definition of characteristic,
and that's the reason we can
always use just plus signs,
because subtraction is
the same as addition.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
We showed --
well, very simple proof.
The order of a subgroup has
to define the order of
the group it's in.
The additive group of the prime
field has order 2 to the
M, so it has to be some divisor
of 2 to the M, which
is a prime.
I think we proved that another
way, but that's
a very simple proof.
OK, great questions, because it
shows you're thinking about
how this relates to what you
learned back in chapter seven.
But at this point you've kind
of got a little vague about
chapter seven, what's
really in there.
By Wednesday, you're really
going to know
chapter seven well.
Let me tell you.
OK.
Good.
Thank you for the help.
Because these are all things
that I should have just said
up here, but they come out much
better, actually, if they
come out in response
to questions.
OK.
So here's one characterization
of a Reed-Solomon code which
apparently you did see.
It's the set of all multiples of
some generator polynomial.
The generator polynomial is
described as this polynomial
of degree n minus k whose roots
are precisely alpha up
through alpha to
the n minus k.
You did say that?
OK.
So similarly, the BCH code --
I'm just going to assert this
just to show you how it goes.
It's the set of all multiples of
g prime of x, which is the
minimal degree binary
polynomial
with the same roots.
Now, how can a binary
polynomial --
alpha to the n minus k.
How can a binary polynomial
have non-binary roots?
Well, it clearly can.
Let's consider g
of prime of x.
It's an element of F2 to the x,
the set of all polynomials
over F2, which is a subset of
over 2 to the M for
the same reason.
F2 is the subfield of F2 to
the M, so some of the
polynomials over F2 to the
M have purely binary
coefficients, all right?
So that's the sense --
that's how we can get between
these two things.
So some binary polynomials have
roots in GF of 2 the M
let me give you an example.
Let's consider x squared plus x
plus 1 as a polynomial in F4
of x, which is certainly is.
It's a polynomial of degree
2 and F4 of x.
What are its roots in F4 of x?
Does it have any roots
in F4 of x?
Does it have any
roots in F2 --
sorry, I'm asking whether
it has any roots in F4.
Now I step back and ask if
it has any roots in F2.
So how do we do that?
We just ask if F of x
is 0 for x equals 0.
We get 1.
So it's not a root of 0.
Substitute 1, we get
1 plus 1 plus 1.
1 is not a root F of x.
All right.
Well, we have two
more candidates.
How about alpha?
For alpha, we get F of alpha
equals alpha squared plus
alpha plus 1.
And if you remember the addition
table of F4, however
it's constructed, this
equals 0, OK?
0, 1, alpha, alpha, squared.
0, 1 alpha, alpha squared.
This is plus.
1, alpha, alpha, squared.
0, 1 plus alpha is
alpha squared.
1 plus alpha squared is alpha.
Any of these is telling
you the same thing.
0, 1, 0, 1 alpha,
squared alpha.
So we conclude from that that 1
plus 1 plus alpha, which is
alpha squared, plus alpha
squared is 0.
So alpha is, in fact,
a root of this.
And what about F of
alpha squared?
Alpha squared squared is alpha
fourth, but we can
reduce that mod 3 --
the exponent mod 3.
So this is alpha plus alpha
squared plus 1 and that is
equal to 0.
So alpha and alpha squared are
roots of this polynomial.
There's a lovely fact proved
in the notes, which is that
every element of --
facts.
Every element of F2 to the
M is a root of x 2
to the M plus x.
OK, did you see something
like this last time?
I see some shaking of heads.
OK.
And how many roots could there
possibly be of x 2 to the M
plus x by the fundamental
theorem of algebra?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the M.
PROFESSOR: 2 to the M. So
that means that x 2 to
the M plus x --
and for every root, it's got to
have a factor of the form x
minus, or in this
case, plus beta.
So this must have a complete
factorization of
the following form.
x 2 to the M plus x is simply
the product of x minus beta.
All right.
In fact, you can see that
0 a root, obviously.
1 is a root, obviously.
And we've checked up here.
Let's see, what are
we interested in?
Here's another example.
x to the fourth plus
1, f of --
if we have g of x equals x to
the four -- sorry -- plus x,
then g of alpha is alpha to
the fourth plus alpha.
But alpha to the fourth is equal
to alpha, so that's 0.
g to the alpha squared
equals alpha to the
8th plus alpha squared.
Alpha to the 8th is alpha to the
fifth is alpha squared, so
that equals 0.
So, in fact, that's true
for that case.
Every irreducible polynomial g
of x and F2 of x whose degree
g of x divides 2 to the M --
is that right?
This may be 2 to
the M minus --
I think it's whose degree
divides M --
is a factor of x to the 2M
plus x in F2 to the x.
OK.
So let's give you an
example again.
Example M equals 2.
This means, what are the
irreducible polynomials whose
degrees divide 2?
The prime polynomials of degree
1 certainly divides to
our x and x plus 1.
Do they divide x to
the fourth plus 1?
Yeah, they do.
How many prime polynomials
are there of degree 2?
There's only one, x squared
plus x plus 1.
And if you divide it out into
x to the fourth plus 1, it
goes evenly.
It turns out that what this
implies is that this is
actually an if or only if.
A polynomial g of x divides x
to 2 to the M plus x if and
only if g of x has a degree
which divides M and g of x is
irreducible.
So this implies that x to the
M plus x factors in F2 of x
into the product of all
irreducible polynomials whose
degrees divide M. And I think
you did a homework problem
that used this, even though it
was never proved in class.
So you at least read about it.
Again, for this example, that
should mean that x to the
fourth plus 1 equals x times
x plus 1 times x
squared plus x plus 1.
Is that true?
Pretty easy to see that it is.
x plus 1 times x squared
plus x plus 1 is just
x cubed plus 1.
Multiply by x --
I'm sorry, this x
fourth plus x.
How many times have
I done this?
Should be x to the
fourth plus x.
Yes.
OK, it's kind of miracle
when you first see it.
This works over any field for
any PNM again, lest you get
this kind of factorization.
OK, but now, comparing this to
this, what does that mean?
That means this is one
factorization.
This is in --
we can do a complete
factorization in
F2 to the M of x.
We can only do complete in the
sense that we reduce it to a
product of degree
1 polynomials.
In F2 of x, we can't do a
complete factorization.
This is similar to, over the
complex field you can always
completely factor a polynomial
into one-dimensional
polynomials of this form, where
beta is the set of roots
of the polynomial.
Whereas over the real field,
you might have to have some
degree 2 polynomials in there.
This is exactly analogous.
You can't get complete
factorization over this subfield.
But what does it mean?
Here we have a polynomial of
degree 4, has 4 roots.
We factor like this.
So each of these factors must
contain a number of roots
equal to its degree.
So what are the roots?
This is the polynomial
that has root 0.
that has root 1.
As we just showed, this is the
polynomial that has the roots
alpha and alpha squared, OK?
So it's always going to
turn out that way.
So you can group the field
elements into subsets where
each subset is the set of roots
of some irreducible
binary polynomial of some degree
that divides M, OK?
These are called cyclotomic
subsets.
Whence the name of Elwyn
Berlekamp's company,
Cyclotomics.
All right.
So this is where, I think, the
theory gets just absolutely
lovely and unexpected, at
least when you start in.
And people who have a taste for
these things, I encourage
you to read a real book
on the subject.
Berlekamp's is one of
the most elegant.
But there are lots --
because it's an elegant subject,
there are lots of
elegant treatments of it.
All right.
So remember what we
were trying to do
in the first place.
We were trying to find the
dimension of BCH codes.
So where are we now?
We've defined a BCH code as
the set of all binary
polynomials with roots alpha up
to alpha to the n minus k
where n and k are the parameters
of the parent
Reed-Solomon code.
And alpha is in the
parent field.
So alpha in
F2 to the M. OK.
One final fact, I guess,
we need to know here.
All right, if alpha is a
root -- now I'm talking
about any field --
then alpha squared is a root
of a binary polynomial.
And again, this is due to a
very lovely fact, which is
that squaring is linear in
fields of characteristic 2.
Why is squaring linear.
A little side calculation.
a plus b squared equals a
squared plus 2ab plus b
squared but characteristic 2.
We can wipe that out.
So in general, f of x quantity
squared is f of x squared.
And that's why, if f of x
evaluates to 0, then f of x
squared must evaluate to 0
since 0 squared is always
equal to 0.
All right.
So alpha is a root if and only
if alpha squared is a root.
Is that true here?
Yes.
Alpha alpha squared.
Well, is it also true if we
squared alpha squared?
What is the square
of alpha squared?
It's back to alpha, all right?
So these sets now turn out to be
cyclotomic cosets, they're
called, which is the set of all
elements and their squares.
We get alpha, alpha squared,
alpha fourth, alpha eighth.
And then, at some point,
it cycles.
Why?
Because what does alpha
to the 2M equal?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
Alpha.
Right.
Alpha to the 2M minus 1 is 1,
so alpha to the 2M is alpha.
So it comes back to alpha
again because of that.
So we get a finite number of
roots which, of course, are
equal to the degree here.
In some cases, it's fewer.
It's whatever the degree is.
It's d, which divides M.
So from this, we
simply start --
suppose we want alpha
to be a root.
Let's start with high
rate codes.
I think here in the example,
in the text, I used F16.
F16 is going to have --
the elements of F16 are going
to be the roots of all the
degree 1, 2, and 4 polynomials
because M is 4 and these are
the degrees that divide 4.
So again, we get x and x plus
1, which have roots 0 and 1.
We get x squared
plus x plus 1.
What are the roots of x squared
plus x plus 1 and F16?
There are only going to be two
of them and they've got to
have the property that if we
start with the first one,
let's call it beta
and beta squared.
Beta fourth has got to
equal beta because we
only have two of them.
That more or less forces beta
to be alpha to the fifth or
alpha to the tenth.
Let's see if that works.
We get alpha to the fifth,
alpha to the tenth.
Square that, we get
alpha to the 20th.
But we now take the exponents
mod 15 and we get
5 again, all right?
So those are the two
roots of x squared
plus x plus 1 in F16.
Obviously, I'm not --
I guess that was a legitimate
proof, but it
was certainly quick.
OK, there are three polynomials
of degree 4.
By the way, I think you can
imagine how, given this
result, we can now
enumerate the
polynomials of each degree.
We now have an expression.
There are two irreducible
polynomials of degree 1.
So how many more of degree 2
is it going to take to make
the overall degree 4?
One of them.
So we're looking
for a single --
there must be a single
irreducible
polynomial degree 4.
Similarly over here, all right,
we've accounted for
four of the elements of F16.
The only other possible degree
we could have is 4.
So how many irreducible
polynomials are there of
degree 4 over in F 2 of x?
Must be three of them.
And it always works out.
So, from this you can get a
closed-form combinatorial
formula again in terms of the
Mobius inversion formula.
By doing a sieve or by some
other method, you can find out
that the three irreducible
polynomials of degree 4 are
those three and the
corresponding roots
for this one --
if this is the irreducible
polynomial you use to define
the field, then alpha is a root
of it and you're going to
get alpha, alpha squared,
alpha fourth,
alpha to the eightth.
Alpha to the eightth squared is
alpha to the 16th, but that
equals alpha, OK?
So these are the roots
of that equation.
Here you get --
sorry, x fourth plus x third
plus 1, since that's basically
the reverse of this, turns out
you get alpha to the minus 1,
which is alpha to the 1fourth.
Square that and you get alpha to
the minus 2, which is alpha
to the 13th, or equivalently,
alpha to the 28 --
reduces to thirteen.
This becomes alpha the 11th,
alpha to the seventh.
and then alpha to the seventh
gives you alpha
to the 1fourth again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
same thing about taking the
square [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Correct.
AUDIENCE: --from the
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Because you go
around in a circle.
So it's a finite set.
So you can obviously
divide by 2.
So there's one cyclotomic
coset.
Here's the second one.
And then the third one must
be whatever's left over.
What's left over?
We don't have alpha
to the third yet.
Alpha to the third, alpha to the
sixth, alpha to the 12th,
and then alpha to the 2fourth,
which is alpha to the ninth.
And alpha to the 18th is equal
alpha to the third again.
OK, what's the moral of this?
We want to start off with --
let's just take a look
at the Reed-Solomon,
the very first one.
We just want n minus k to be 1
and we just want to have root
alpha in here.
Well, if we get root alpha,
we're going to get root alpha
squared, alpha fourth and alpha
eightth along with it.
If we want a binary polynomial
with root alpha,
it has to this one.
And it's going to
have four roots.
All right.
So for root alpha, we're going
to get x fourth plus x plus 1
as our generator polynomial.
And it's actually going
to have roots
alpha and alpha squared.
So it's going to be the same
one as you would get if you
wanted alpha and
alpha squared.
That means n minus k is already
up to 2, which means
your distance is already
up to 3.
Distance is n minus k plus 1.
So this leads to a code
with n equals 16 --
is that right?
Yes.
BCH codes are always defined
to be one shorter.
We're going to have four
redundant bits, so k equals 12
and distance equals 3.
I think that's not
quite right.
When we're doing BCH codes,
they're always defined just on
the non-zero elements
of the field.
So we start with the shorter
Read-Solomon code of
length q minus 1.
15 in this case rather
than 16.
And 0 never appears here as
one of the possible roots.
So let me just do that.
I apologize I haven't
carried through all
the possible steps.
So we're getting all of the
polynomial multiples of x
fourth plus x plus 1 of degree
less or equal to
14 rather than 15.
So it's n equals 15.
n minus k is going to be 4.
So this is 11.
And the distance is going to
be greater than equal to 3.
In fact, it is 3.
So it's a 15, 11, 3
code, which is, in
fact, the Hamming code.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
Wasn't this fun?
You're supposed to
do that, Ashish.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, well, so you
can see how it goes.
So this gets us both roots
alpha and alpha squared.
If we want alpha third and alpha
fourth, we already have
alpha fourth from
this polynomial.
So all we need is this one,
which gets us another.
And that gives us an n equals
15, k equals 7, d greater than
or equal to 5, which, in fact,
is a 15, 7, 5 code.
So we get additional codes.
There's a table in there that
shows you that most the time
for short block lengths for
distances which are equal to a
prime power, we get the
same parameters
as Reed-Muller codes.
For lengths 64 and higher,
sometimes we do
a little bit better.
In addition, we get a lot more
codes for every, basically,
odd distance when you take the
length odd or even distance if
you take the length even.
And that's definitely an asset,
that you have a larger
number of codes to
choose from.
So there's no doubt that in
terms n, k, d, BCH is the
larger and, for longer block
length, slightly better class
than Reed-Muller codes.
But as I said before, in terms
of performance versus
complexity, Reed-Muller
might still be the
ones you want to use.
OK.
Good luck in the review and
good luck in the exam.
I will see you Wednesday.